مشروع سقف الدين يعبر اختباره الثاني
بالتصويت عليه في مجلس النواب
وخلال النقاش حول التشريع تبادلت
الديمقراطيون والجمهوريون التهمه بالتسبب
بازمه سقف الدين
منذ البدايه كان الديموقراطيون واضحين
اننا لن نسمح للجمهوريين من الماجا
بالتخلف عن سداد ديوننا او تحطيم الاقتصاد
او التسبب بركود يقتل الوظائف
منطقيا انه فيما نعالج المشكله التي تسبب
بها الرئيس بايدن عبر انفاق اموال ليست
لدينا لسنوات ان نبدا في حلها
لكن رغم معارضه جمهوريين يمينيين
وديمقراطيين تقدميين كان التفاؤل سيد
الموقف حيث عبر رئيس المجلس كابل مكارتي
عن ثقته بتمرير التشريع
الليله ستكون مختلفه الليله سنقوم بشيء لم
نقم به من قبل سنمنح امريكا الامل
الجمهوريون مرروا قبل ذلك قاعده تحكم
النقاش حول التشريع ما مهد الطريق لمروره
النهائي حيث قدمت ديمقراطيون مساعدتهم
بعدما صوت ضده 29 جمهوريا
الخطوه التاليه ستكون في مجلس الشيوخ حيث
يحشد زعيم الحزبين الدعم لتمريره في اسرع
وقت ممكن دعم بدا في تاييد زعيم
الجمهوريين في المجلس للتشريع
ما امل ان يحدثه هو ان اولئك الذين لديهم
تعديلات اذا حصلوا على التصويت ان يحفظوا
الوقت حتى نتمكن من انهاء الامر الخميس او
الجمعه وتهدئه البلد والاسواق الموقف نفسه
عبر عنه زعيم الديمقراطيين في المجلس
تشومر المدير قدما في هذا الاتفاق هو
الشيء المعقول والمسؤول الذي يجب القيام
به والاكثر حيويه بالنسبه الى بلدنا
وان تمرير المشروع في مجلس الشيوخ ستبقى
الخطوه الاخيره توقيع الرئيس عليه ليصبح
قنونا حسين الطاوض العربيه واشنطن لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات